Anflug auf Jakutien
im Nordosten Sibiriens.
Ich sehe viel Wasser. Hoffentlich
nicht zu viel für unser Abenteuer.
Vielleicht schafft man es
bis zur Hälfte der Strecke
und bleibt dann stecken - wegen des
Hochwassers, weil es so viel regnet.
Dann muss man warten,
bis das Wasser wieder sinkt.
Das sind alles
Bergbäche oder Bergflüsse,
die dann immer höher werden.
- Und da müssen wir überall durch.
Ja, und auf einmal kommst du
weder vorwärts noch rückwärts.
Okay.
* Christof lacht. *
Mein Name ist Christof Franzen.
Ich war elf Jahre
Russlandkorrespondent
des Schweizer Fernsehens.
In diese abgelegene Gegend Sibiriens
reiste ich bereits im Jahr 2011 -
eine der schönsten Drehreisen
meiner Korrespondentenzeit.
Damals porträtierte ich
den Nomadenjungen Christafor
und erlebte Geschichten, die mir bis
heute in Erinnerung geblieben sind.
Eine davon ist der Versuch,
ein neugeborenes Rentier zu retten.
Die Mutter wollte es nicht säugen.
(Mann) Gib ihm den Finger!
Hauptsache ist, dass das Kleine
endlich zu saugen anfängt.
(Junge) Ja, es saugt, es saugt.
Ein kleines Bisschen.
Eine Kindheit
im Einklang mit der Taiga -
mit viel Freiheit, aber
auch schon grosser Verantwortung.
Meine Korrespondentenzeit in Russland
geht bald zu Ende.
Mir war immer klar: An diesen Ort
möchte ich noch einmal zurückkehren.
Wie geht es Christafor heute?
Ist das Leben dort immer noch so ur-
sprünglich wie in meiner Erinnerung?
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Dave, was meinst ...
* Der Guide spricht russisch. *
Brauchen wir so was?
- Hast du das nicht?
Probier mal!
* Der Guide spricht russisch. *
Das ist mein Regisseur Dave.
Er ist Russlandgreenhorn
und neugierig auf Sibirien.
Ich hoffe, er weiss,
worauf er sich eingelassen hat.
Letztes Mal
reiste ich bequem per Helikopter.
Jetzt wollen wir
dieses extreme Gebiet
so erleben wie die Einheimischen -
über Land und ungefiltert.
Mein treuer Kameramann Schenja
wird die Expedition
in den russischen fernen Osten
für die Nachwelt festhalten.
Der Mann im blauen Jackett ist Slava,
unser einheimischer Guide.
Er hätte uns ruhig sagen können,
dass das Abenteuer
bereits auf dem Parkplatz beginnt.
Ah!
- Uh!
* Der Guide spricht russisch. *
Das ist noch gar nichts.
Dort, in der Taiga, gibt es
viele davon. Die gleichen Insekten.
Wir befinden uns in Jakutsk -
5'000 km östlich von Moskau.
Von hier fahren wir 1'000 km
auf einer der angeblich
gefährlichsten Strassen der Welt
bis Ust-Nera.
Von unserem Zielort Sasyr soll
ein Lkw kommen, der uns dort abholt.
Dann geht es 200 km
durch absolute Wildnis nach Sasyr
und noch mal 50 km weiter
zu den Rentiernomaden
und dem Jungen Christafor.
* Gemächliche Klänge *
Fahrer Sergej
soll uns bis nach Ust-Nera bringen.
Doch wir wissen nicht, ob wir
von dort überhaupt weiterkommen.
Die Wolken am Himmel
verheissen nichts Gutes.
* Rufton *
* Männliche Stimme am Handy *
Wie ist die Situation bei euch?
Das Wasser kommt.
* Slava spricht russisch. *
Der Truck
ist noch nicht losgefahren, oder?
(Mann) Nein, noch nicht.
Wir sind unterwegs auf der
Kolyma Road, der einzigen Strasse,
welche die Städte Magadan,
Jakutsk und Ust-Nera verbindet.
Die Strasse
wird auch Strasse der Knochen
oder Strasse des Todes genannt,
weil sie
von Gulag-Häftlingen erbaut wurde.
In den 30er-Jahren,
als sie hier Gold fanden ...
Sobald sie wussten, es hat Gold,
brauchten sie Strassen.
Sie brauchten billige Arbeitskräfte.
Gulag - so wurden Straflager
zur Stalin-Zeit genannt.
Darin kamen Millionen Menschen
ums Leben.
Allein entlang
dieser 2'000 km langen Strasse
gab es 800'000 Gefangene.
Tausende starben.
* Aufwühlende Klänge *
Jakutien
ist die grösste Region Sibiriens
und die kälteste bewohnte Region
der Erde.
Im Winter
wird es hier kälter als -60 °C.
Im Winter ist es schwer,
einen Toten zu begraben.
Dafür muss man die Erde auftauen.
Als die Strasse gebaut wurde,
hat man die Leichen einfach
in den entstandenen Graben geworfen.
Die Überreste liegen eigentlich
noch unter der Strasse.
Wir erreichen
das ostsibirische Bergland.
Ein Vorgeschmack
auf das Ziel unserer Reise.
Wunderschön, aber gefährlich.
* Slava spricht russisch. *
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Er ist eingeschlafen.
Hilft der Rettungsdienst nicht?
Woher soll hier
ein Rettungsdienst kommen?
Braucht er irgendetwas zu essen
oder zu trinken?
* Christof übersetzt auf Russisch. *
Zu essen habe ich.
Er hat mir einen Zettel
mit Handynummern gegeben,
die ich anrufen soll.
Wir haben ein Satellitentelefon.
Ruf doch gleich jetzt an!
* Er spricht russisch. *
Ich bin in den Graben gefahren,
eingeschlafen.
Ja, ich scheine ganz zu sein.
Weisst du, wie viele in Russland
pro Jahr
auf der Strasse ums Leben kommen?
Nein.
- Schätz mal!
2'000.
- 27'000.
27'000?
- Ja.
Seine Retter sind 1'000 km entfernt.
Das bedeutet auf dieser Strasse
mind. zwei Tage.
Die Kolyma Road gilt als eine
der gefährlichsten Strassen der Welt.
Sogar Reifentests
werden hier durchgeführt.
Auch wir merken schnell einmal,
wie heimtückisch sie sein kann.
* Lockere Musik *
Die Rohre unter der Strasse konnten
der Strömung nicht standhalten.
Es hat sie weggeschwemmt.
Jetzt versuchen wir,
eine Durchfahrt zu machen.
Wie lange dauert das?
Das hängt davon ab,
wie schnell das Wasser sinkt.
Je schneller,
desto besser kommen wir voran.
Jeder Fluss ist einmalig.
Haben Sie gesehen, wie tief der ist?
Wir schütten es rein,
es wird wieder weggeschwemmt.
Dann bleibt die Tiefe genau gleich.
Gibt es eine Alternative,
das zu umfahren?
Nein,
dort sieht es noch schlimmer aus.
Das passiert jedes Jahr.
Einige Orte sind schwach.
Man müsste sie verstärken.
Dafür bräuchte man Geld.
Jetzt baut man
die Brücke vom Festland zur Krim.
Ja, dort wird die Brücke gebaut.
Hier haben wir einen Dreck.
Solche Brücken.
* Gemächliche Musik *
Im besten Fall also
den ganzen Tag warten.
Zumindest hat das Wasser
den Höchststand wohl hinter sich.
Für unsere Mitwartenden
scheint die Situation
nicht so aussergewöhnlich zu sein.
Zeit wird in Jakutien
mit anderen Massstäben gemessen.
Das spürte ich schon
bei meinem letzten Besuch.
Sasyr ist ein 700-Einwohner-Dorf.
Im Umkreis von 200 km
nichts als Taiga, Berge und Flüsse.
Hier gehen die Kinder
der Rentiernomaden zur Schule
und verbringen
geschlagene neun Monate im Jahr
getrennt von ihren Familien
und ihren Rentierherden.
Christafor lebte während der
Schulzeit im Haus seiner Cousine.
Hier im Dorf
erlebte ich ihn wie ausgewechselt.
Kaum 20 Worte sprach er
während des gesamten Drehs mit mir.
Ich begleitete ihn in die Schule,
die er nicht besonders mochte.
Beim Sätzebilden wurde mir klar,
wo er mit seinen Gedanken war.
Sobald die Schule zu Ende ist, reise
ich sofort zu meinen Rentieren.
Hallo!
* Er spricht russisch. *
Wir sind in Ust-Nera.
Ust-Nera.
Wir wollen von Ust-Nera nach Sasyr.
Wir haben vielleicht einen Fahrer.
Wie sind die Wege?
(Frau) Das Wasser steht hoch.
Es scheint sogar
noch gestiegen zu sein.
Mit zwei Tagen Verspätung
haben wir dann doch noch die
Goldgräberstadt Ust-Nera erreicht.
"Mündung der Nera"
bedeutet dieser Name.
Und die Nera zeigt uns deutlich:
immer noch Hochwasser.
Die Verspätung ist egal.
Der Lastwagen aus Sasyr,
der uns abholen sollte,
ist gar nicht erst losgefahren.
Unsere letzte Hoffnung ist Vasilly,
auch ein Fahrer aus Sasyr,
der hier
zusammen mit seinen Passagieren
angeblich schon
seit zwei Wochen festsitzt.
* Sie begrüssen sich auf Russisch. *
Wir waren schon mal in Sasyr
zum Filmen - vor sechs Jahren.
In der Schule und so.
Jetzt wollen wir wieder dorthin -
mit Ihnen.
Unser Auto. Damit fahren wir.
Oh!
* Er lacht. *
Hat es Platz?
Da.
Wo wir da ... Wo wir noch Platz ...
* Er lacht. *
Da hat es eine Fischerrute.
Eine Angelrute.
- Und ein Boot.
- Und ein paar Fässer, Räder ...
Hat es noch Platz für uns?
- Keine Ahnung, wie die da ...
Wenn er sagt,
es kommen noch weitere zwölf mit ...
Er hätte ein bisschen ...
... aufräumen können.
Das wäre kein Luxus gewesen.
Wie lange brauchen wir?
* Er spricht russisch. *
Zwei Tage oder einen Monat.
Alles ist möglich. Die Strecke.
Hier, für euch.
Die habe ich
aus einem verlassenen Haus geholt,
damit ihr es bequem habt.
Vasilly ist das zum Schutz?
Nein, das ist für die Jagd.
* Unruhige, aufreibende Klänge *
* Ächzen *
Hoppla!
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Was? Dave?
* Er spricht russisch. *
Nicht filmen!
Die werden dann
auch wieder mal nüchtern.
Das Wichtigste ist,
unseren Wodka zu verstecken.
Zugegeben, jetzt wäre ich lieber
in diesem Flugzeug.
Doch es ist schon
eine einmalige Gelegenheit.
Eine solche Reise
kann man nicht planen.
* Spannende Musik *
Slava versucht, unseren Regisseur
etwas aufzumuntern.
Ich will schöne Natur sehen.
Deshalb mache ich diese Reise mit.
Es ist ein langer und schwieriger
Weg, aber exzellente Natur.
Zumindest das.
Doch die Natur zeigt sich erst einmal
von ihrer unerbittlichen Seite.
Schon der erste Fluss, den wir
überqueren müssen, führt Hochwasser.
Ein Versuch,
die Götter milde zu stimmen,
scheint momentan
die einzige Idee zu sein.
Wie sieht es aus, Vassily?
Wir überlegen,
wie wir da rüberkommen.
Die Zivilisation liegt hinter uns.
Wenn das Wasser zurückgeht,
fahren wir.
Sonst heisst es warten -
egal, wie lange.
Unsere Reisegefährten sind Ewenen,
wie die Rentiernomaden.
Eine Volksgruppe von weniger als
20'000 Menschen mit eigener Sprache.
Jeder von ihnen scheint genau
zu wissen, wo er anpacken muss.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Kommt, es gibt Tee!
Nachts sind hier
selbst im Sommer kalte 0 °C.
Wir sind so weit im Norden,
dass es nur noch
für knapp 2 Std. richtig dunkel wird.
Im Morgengrauen wird schmerzhaft
deutlich, was noch vor uns liegt.
Von atemberaubender Natur
sind wir noch weit entfernt.
Hier haben Goldgräber gewütet.
Auch nach der kurzen Nacht
keine wesentliche Veränderung.
Weiterfahrt immer noch unmöglich.
* Schwere, müde Klänge *
Siehst du das Fahrerhäuschen
da hinten?
Da ist ein Lastwagen umgekippt.
Oh, den hat es ja ganz umgedreht.
Ein Ural wie unserer?
Ja.
Und die Leute?
Haben sie es geschafft?
Ja,
sie konnten rechtzeitig springen.
Also, sei vorsichtig!
Es ist sehr gefährlich.
Keine leichte Entscheidung, oder?
- Wir müssen gut nachdenken.
So viele Leute.
Kinder, Ausländer ...
Das wäre ein Skandal.
Ja, ein internationaler.
Da ist ein Fahrzeug.
- Der hat es rübergeschafft.
* Lockere Musik *
Er sagt, wenn wir hier vorbei sind,
ist das Schlimmste durch.
Das meint er.
Wieso meint er das?
Weil da theoretisch
am meisten Wasser sein müsste.
Dieser Flussteil ist der unterste.
- Aha.
Wenn wir kippen, sollen wir springen.
Aber in welche Richtung?
Ich muss
ein bisschen Gegengewicht geben.
Hei-ei-ei!
Ich weiss nicht, wie viel Schräge
er noch ausgehalten hätte.
Vielleicht haben mich
meine 100 kg hier gerettet.
* Langgezogene Mundharmonika-Klänge *
Leider war die Prognose bezüglich ab-
nehmender Tiefe der Flüsse daneben.
So geht es dahin.
Stunde um Stunde, Fluss um Fluss.
Unsere Arche
riecht nach Abgasen und Menschlichem.
Unsere Mitreisenden
nehmen es mit stoischer Gelassenheit.
Selbst die Kinder beklagen sich nie.
* Langgezogene Mundharmonika-Klänge *
Wie heissen Sie?
- Oigulana.
Wie?
Wie lange dauert die Fahrt?
Manchmal drei Tage, manchmal zehn.
Zehn Tage.
- Ja.
Einmal sind wir im Winter
bei -50 °C gefahren.
Dann ist uns
das Lenkrad eingefroren.
Wir mussten es
mit dem Gasbrenner wieder auftauen.
Oigulana ist Biologiestudentin
in Jakutsk
und fährt zweimal im Jahr
heim nach Sasyr.
Ich könnte mir so eine Reise
bei -50 °C nicht vorstellen.
Das feuchte Moos
fühlt sich schon jetzt bitterkalt an.
Selbst im kurzen Sommer
ist der Boden hier wenige Meter
unter der Oberfläche gefroren.
Doch der nächste Tag
bringt eine Überraschung.
Elche in freier Natur.
* Schuss *
Der Elch hinkt.
Die nervöse Unruhe auf der Ladefläche
macht es nicht gerade einfach,
zu zielen.
Jägerglück.
Der angeschossene Elch
flieht ausgerechnet über die einzige
Schneefläche weit und breit.
Vassily,
nehmt ihr das ganze Fleisch mit?
Ja, klar.
Fährt das Fleisch bei uns mit?
Ja, ein neuer Passagier.
Was fühlen Sie, wenn Sie das sehen?
Es tut mir schon leid. Aber es wäre
eine Sünde, sich zu beschweren.
Man sollte dankbar sein.
Das ist ein Geschenk der Natur.
Was bedeutet das Tier für Sie?
Das ist zusätzliches Fleisch.
Im Sommer
essen wir oft nur Dosenfleisch.
Das ist Frischfleisch - eine Freude.
Was ist denn Ihr Lieblingsstück?
Suppe aus den Rippen.
Und die Nieren gebraten.
Sibirisches Sushi.
Die Leber
verzehrt man am besten frisch.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Wir werden nicht eingeladen.
Und das ist gut so.
Und?
Dein Eindruck?
Hm?
Das wilde Sibirien.
Mit dem Fahrtwind wird es ja
hoffentlich nicht mehr so riechen.
Trotz allem beindruckend,
wie Frauen, Männer und Kinder
genau wissen, was zu tun ist.
Was für ein Erlebnis!
Jetzt wäre eine Dusche
nicht schlecht.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Eigentlich ganz unterhaltsam,
würden wir nicht geschlagene 6 Std.
mit einem Elch
unter diesem Dach verbringen.
* Ruhige, mystische Musik *
Jeden schönen Moment in Sibirien
muss man sich hart erarbeiten.
* Sanfte Musik *
An besonderen Orten haben Schamanen
Opferstellen eingerichtet.
Hier ist ausserdem
das Tor zum Nationalpark Moma.
Wo ist Sasyr?
Hier.
Und hier ist dann die Rentierherde.
Sasyr ist schön,
aber sehr abgelegen.
Ja, etwas weit.
Die Jungen ziehen weg. Sie machen
Ausbildungen in der Stadt.
Sie haben fünf Kinder?
Der Mittlere sagt, nach der achten
Klasse kommt er zu meiner Herde.
Wir lassen sie ja in die Stadt,
um zu studieren.
Vielleicht
sollte ich sie nicht gehen lassen.
Hier ist es doch viel besser.
Nächster Tag,
nächste Herausforderung.
Wie sieht es aus?
Wir müssen aussen rumfahren.
Könnten wir über das Eis fahren,
wären wir viel schneller.
Doch wir haben sowieso längst
jegliches Gefühl für Zeit verloren.
Was mir, Christof aus der Schweiz,
zunehmend als Tortur erscheint,
war für den Nomadenjungen Christafor
damals der schönste Tag des Jahres.
Nach neun Monaten Schule in Sasyr
durfte er im Frühjahr
endlich zu seiner Herde reisen.
Eine Fahrt,
die selbst für den Fahrer Victor
mit seinem Vezdekhod
eine Herausforderung war.
Nach über 12 Std. musste noch
ein letzter Pass bezwungen werden.
Iegor, schau mal, dort hinten!
Dann kam endlich der Moment, auf den
Christafor so lange gewartet hatte:
das Wiedersehen mit seiner Familie.
Zuerst begrüsste ihn sein Vater
Dmitry, dann seine Mutter Jekatarina.
Selbst bei den zurückhaltenden Ewenen
konnte ich die Freude
hier und da spüren.
Und? Noch motiviert?
Ja, ja. Jetzt umso mehr.
Jetzt ... ai! Jetzt erst recht.
Der Wettergott war mit uns.
Nach vier Tagen erreichen wir Sasyr.
Noch alles da.
* Hundebellen *
Die Hunde sind auch noch da.
Zuerst verlässt uns
die mittlerweile nüchterne Familie.
* Sie verabschieden sich
auf Russisch. *
Und, wie war die Reise?
Wir sind es uns gewohnt.
Wir reisen oft.
Wann ist die nächste Reise?
Von mir aus schon morgen.
* Sie lacht. *
* Sanfte Musik *
Sasyr ist einer der entlegensten
Orte, die ich mir vorstellen kann.
Das Ende des Riesenreiches Russland.
Der Rand der Zivilisation.
Schon als Kind
schaute ich Reiseserien im Fernsehen
und träumte davon,
eines Tages auch so etwas zu erleben.
Bei meinem ersten Besuch
und auch heute fühlt es sich an wie:
Jetzt bist du angekommen.
* Lachen und Rufe der Kinder *
Leider ist hier
nicht das Ziel unserer Reise.
Und wir haben ein Problem.
Wir wollen
zu den Rentiernomaden in den Bergen.
Die einzige Möglichkeit,
dorthin zu kommen,
ist mein alter Bekannter Victor
mit seinem Vezdekhod.
Doch man sagte uns,
er sei krank und fahre nicht mehr.
Hallo, Europa.
Erinnern Sie sich an mich?
Natürlich, Christof.
Du bist nur
ein bisschen älter geworden.
Hat dich Sasyr wieder?
Ja, es ist wie ein Sumpf,
der einen nicht mehr loslässt.
Möchtet ihr wieder zu den Rentieren?
- Das hängt jetzt von Ihnen ab.
Fahren Sie nicht mehr Vezdekhod?
Doch.
Es gibt das Gerücht, man könne Sie
nicht mehr dazu überreden.
Das ging um diese Geologen.
Jetzt habe ich gar nicht gefragt,
wie es Ihnen geht.
Ich will nicht sagen, gut.
Im Winter
hatte ich drei Operationen.
Aber im Sommer
arbeite ich jetzt als Goldwäscher.
Ehrlich? Mit Erfolg?
Ja. In den Bergen
gibt es überall Gold.
Victor verbringt
den ganzen Sommer in den Bergen,
und er sei gesund genug,
um Vezdekhod zu fahren.
Die Geologen hat er aus einem
anderen Grund nicht transportiert.
Im Dorf geht die Angst um,
die grossen Goldunternehmen
könnten kommen und Sasyr ausradieren.
Es wird sogar
von einer Initiative gesprochen,
die das Dorf als UNESCO-Kulturerbe
schützen lassen will.
* Langgezogene Mundharmonika-Klänge *
Noch eine letzte Tagesreise
liegt vor uns.
Wir wissen mittlerweile,
was das bedeuten kann.
Und schon kurz nach der Müllkippe
haben wir das Gefühl,
unser Vezdekhod
könnte schrottreif sein.
* Gemächliche Countryklänge *
Und schon das nächste Problem.
Wir sind hinten zu leicht,
um in diesem Sumpf voranzukommen.
Noch mal kurz die Kette flicken, dann
besorgen wir den nötigen Ballast.
* Motorsägenlärm *
Victor ist der Typ
wortkarger Taiga-Clint-Eastwood.
Gibt es ein Problem,
denkt er im Stillen nach.
Und dann
macht er garantiert etwas Krasses.
* Christof ruft lachend. *
* Sanfte Musik, Surren von Insekten *
* Metallisches Quietschen *
Nach 11 Std. haben wir
zumindest die Berge erreicht.
Es ist schön, zu wissen,
dass es das noch gibt.
Orte, an denen die Zeit
irgendwie relativ richtig ist,
wo du auch nicht
pünktlich sein kannst,
weil du einfach nicht weisst,
was geschieht.
Irgendwie hat das was.
Ich weiss ja:
Die Moderne hat auch Sasyr
und die Nomaden längst eingeholt.
Schon vor sechs Jahren kam gerade
der erste Internetanschluss ins Dorf.
Ob Christafor wohl immer noch
so heimatverbunden ist?
Oder folgt auch der Nomadenjunge
dem Ruf der Stadt?
Ah, da!
Ein bisschen aufgeregt.
* Aufreibende Musik *
Geh einfach!
* Sie begrüssen sich auf Russisch. *
Wie geht es euch?
Gut.
Unser Sohn ist erwachsen geworden.
Ist da Luft drin oder sind die echt?
- Die sind echt.
Kommen Sie rein!
Ihnen ist sicher kalt.
Ja, wir sind 13 Std. gefahren.
* Hundebellen *
Schau mal!
In welcher Klasse warst du damals?
In der fünften.
Wie alt bist du jetzt?
17.
Ich erfahre,
dass Christafor auch heute
nur im Sommer bei den Rentieren
und seiner Familie lebt.
Er wohnt jetzt in der Stadt Jakutsk
und macht dort
eine Ausbildung als Baggerfahrer.
Jetzt noch ein Jahr,
dann kann ich in die Armee.
Wirklich? Wieso?
Ich will es so.
Dort, wo sie mich nehmen.
Nach der Armee
bekommt man leichter eine Arbeit.
Wie gefällt es dir in der Stadt?
- Ich habe mich daran gewöhnt.
Christafor ist immer noch
so wortkarg wie damals.
Er ist wohl eher ein Mann der Tat.
Jeden Morgen werden die Rentiere
von ihren Weiden in den Bergen
ins Lager geholt.
Die Rentiere ernähren sich
von diesem Kraut, das Jagel heisst.
Eine Woche dauert es,
bis die Weiden abgefressen sind.
Dann zieht das gesamte Lager weiter.
Das Ankommen der Herde war schon
letztes Mal ein Erlebnis für mich.
* Sanfte, gefühlvolle Musik *
Rund 900 Rentiere
hat Christafors Familie.
Die Nomaden
produzieren Fleisch und Fell.
Der Export von hier
ist allerdings schwierig.
Sie leben hauptsächlich
von staatlichen Subventionen.
Heute ist Medizintag.
Verletzte oder kranke Rentiere
müssen eingefangen werden,
um sie behandeln zu können.
Christafor
scheint ganz in seinem Element.
Dennoch konnte er sich
noch nicht entscheiden,
ob seine Zukunft in der Stadt
oder bei den Rentieren liegt.
Was fehlt dir,
wenn du in Jakutsk bist?
Das habe ich
doch gestern schon gesagt.
Komm! Noch mal!
Die Berge, die Natur ...
... die Rentiere.
* Sanfte Musik *
Wir werden die Rentiere
auch vermissen.
Sie sind extrem zutraulich
und lieben Salz.
Christafors Eltern haben erkannt,
welch positiven Effekt der Kontakt
mit diesen Tieren haben kann.
Seit 20 Jahren laden sie Waisenkinder
oder Kinder aus Problemfamilien
dazu ein,
den Sommer hier zu verbringen.
* Kinderstimmen, Hundebellen *
Den Kindern
tut der Aufenthalt sichtlich gut.
Bist du der Gewinner?
Unser Ziel war, dass die Kinder
Rentierzüchter bleiben wollen.
Wir mussten feststellen,
dass die Jungen das nicht wollen.
Die Kinder, die im Sommer
hier waren, werden erwachsen.
Sie gehen in die Armee
oder heiraten.
Manche machen eine Ausbildung
und wollen nicht hierher.
In den Ferien kommen sie gerne.
Sie erinnern sich manchmal
und rufen an.
Das freut uns.
Leider ist unser Aufenthalt wegen
der langen Anreise viel zu kurz.
Allzu viele Worte hat Christafor
auch bei diesem Treffen
nicht mit mir gesprochen.
Doch wir verabreden,
über Facebook in Kontakt zu bleiben.
Junge Rentierzüchter
gehen mit der Zeit.
* Sie singen ein russisches Lied. *
Ich bin wieder beeindruckt, wie
warmherzig wir hier empfangen wurden.
Irgendetwas scheint dieser Ort
mit mir zu machen.
Ich glaube, meinen Begleitern
geht es ganz ähnlich.
Das ist nur der Wind.
* Unruhige Musik *
Wieder so ein Moment, der mir noch
lange im Gedächtnis bleiben wird.
Und ich stelle mir schon die Frage:
Wie lange wird es hier noch so sein?
Und werde ich
wohl jemals zurückkommen?
Ein schöner Moment,
aber irgendwie auch ein trauriger.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Daniela Zacheo - 2018
In der nächsten Folge
bin ich in der russischen
Kulturhauptstadt St. Petersburg.
Mit einer
ganz besonderen Herausforderung
zum Abschluss meiner Korrespondenten-
zeit abseits der Politik.
Ich will in einem russisch-orthodoxen
Chor mitsingen.
Der bekannte Kirchenchor der Isaaks-
Kathedrale lädt mich zum Casting ein.